They're attractive.
>> Yes. But not
>> No. No. No. No. No. No. No. Do you find
her attractive? Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> Do you find her attractive? Yes or no?
>> Okay. If you find her attractive as a
man, would you not want to be intimate
with an attractive woman?
>> No.
>> Why people still watch this guy? I will
never understand. But you want a logical
explanation. So, I will provide.
>> Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when his soul is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, Omrah, Salah, fasting. No
sodaka brothers and sisters is getting
thousands of shahadas monthly yearly.
Hundreds of thousands of people are
coming to Islam. They are printing Quran
distributing material training duat.
Brothers and sisters, do you want the
part of that goes on forever. This is
how Islam has spread around the world.
Brothers and sisters, carry on this
legacy of the prophetam inshallah by
donating whatever amount inshallah and
ayra right now inshallah. Enjoy the
video. Asalamaikum welcome to brothers
and sisters and dear friends. This video
is going to be very, very informative.
And it's going to show you, subhan
Allah, how
sisters in general and females are so
out of touch with male psychology,
biology, the way we're created, how
Allah's created us. And this sister
who's done many videos about me on
multiple occasions, which I've didn't
really have the time to respond, I'll be
honest with you, accusations,
speculations, uh, disrespect sometimes,
and it's okay. She's my sister in Islam,
and I forgive her for those remarks. But
I want to stick to specifically the
Quran Sunnah and I want to talk about
research and studies not for my own self
but let's stick to that research and
studies because very interestingly she's
reacting to me giving da to two
non-Muslims three non-Muslims two are
male and one's a female and I'm talking
about how men and women cannot be
friends because of a variety of reasons.
Now she disagrees with me but does she
disagree with me based on evidence from
Islam based on evidence from the Quran
and the Sunnah based on evidence from
evidence from studies and research?
Nope. She disagrees with me because
because it's me. Let's watch for ourel
inshallah and dissect with evidences
over evidences ample amount amount of
evidences which absolutely with all due
respect show the contrary that men and
women cannot be friends and then I have
a question for her. What is her
disagreement with me on what basis?
Let's get to inshallah.
>> They're attractive.
>> Yes. But beyond.
>> No no no no no no.
>> Do you find her attractive? Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. If you find her attractive as a
man, would you not want to be intimate
with an attractive woman?
>> No.
>> Let me just get this right. I find a
woman attractive, but I don't want to be
with her. Can you logically, as a man,
tell me how that makes sense.
>> Why people still watch this guy, I will
never understand, but she wants a
logical explanation. So, I will provide.
>> Okay, good. Firstly, number one, she's
saying, "I do not know why people would
listen to me." Okay. On what basis
should they not listen to me? Are you
going to bring evidence from the Quran,
the Sunnah, Allah and his messenger,
studies, research? Or is it based on
personal attacks of who I am or you have
a disagreement of what what what is that
I say? Most of the times it's not that
you have an issue with myself. It's that
there's issues with what Islam pertains
to and what Islam says and you know that
if you have an issue with that, it can
leave you in dangerous ground. So what
you do? You throw Muslims, people in the
da da bros like myself under the bus at
the pretense of your disagreement is
with me. No, it's not. disagree with
disagreement is with Allah and his
messenger and how he has created us. So
let's get straight into what she has to
say.
>> That way your perspective and your
conclusion is not logical. You are
presupposing that recognizing that
someone's conventionally attractive and
being sexually attracted to them or
having sexual intent are the same things
and they're not. And you're also
assuming that because a man might be
sexually attracted to a woman that he
will go on to pursue that and that he
must or else it's illogical. This is so
hedonistic. Are we barbaric?
>> Okay, good. So she said is he is this
hedenistic and is this barbaric? You can
already see she's given terminologies to
certain things. Number one, you are not
a man. You can't talk on that specific
matter. Are you a man to be talking
about? It's like me talking about child
birth. Do you know guys, child birth?
You know, if you think about it, it's
actually it's not really that hard.
Excuse me. With all your respect, did
you give birth? No. Why are you talking
on our behalf on something that we go
through? I wouldn't talk about matters
that does I do not understand. So, the
here is you're giving it barbarism and
hedaism. Why? Because we're talking
about a man's psych psychology and
physiology and the way he is created.
Now the question is for example let's go
to like studies I don't want to talk out
my just you know just talking for the
sake of it in okay she's claiming that
this is wrong I'm going to ask a
question on what basis men and women
cannot be friends why are you are you
not a Muslim woman as far as I know
you're a Muslim why are you trying to
say they can be now let's look at for
example some studies one study that
shows the sex drive refers to the
strength of sexual motivation across
many different studies and measures men
have shown to have more frequent and
more intense sexual desires than women
as reflected in spontaneous thoughts
about sex frequency and variety of
sexual fantasies desire frequency of
intercourse, desired number of partners,
masturbation, liking for various sexual
practices, willingness to forgo sex,
initiating versus refusing sex, making
sacrifices for sex, and other measures.
No contrary findings indicating stronger
sexual motivation among women were
found. Hence, we conclude that the male
sex drive is stronger than the female
sex drive. The gender differences in sex
drive should not be generalized other
should not be generalized to other
constructs such as sexual or orgasmic
capacity, enjoyment of sex or ex
extrinsical motivated uh motivation of
sex. Okay. Now, so the first thing that
you've done is you are denying the way
we are created. No, no, no, no. Why?
Because as a woman because you do not
see the woman in a man in that way. Oh,
I might find him handsome but I don't
think a sexual way. Good. That's you,
not us. And then it's like if you're
like that, you're barbering, hedonism,
what kind of a man are you, etc. And
we've got studies after studies. And not
only that, in Islam, it makes it very
clear that this is not uh this is
absolutely normal. It's natural. But
let's carry on in
>> attraction and sexual desire are not the
same thing. You can find something
physically appealing, physically
aesthetic or harmonious and not want to
sexually engage with it. And an easy
reputation to this is, would you say
that your mother or your sister or your
daughter is an attractive woman? I would
hope so. I would hope you think highly
of the woman in your life. If I say my
father is handsome, does that now make
it logically the case that I might I'm
I'm sexually attracted to my father?
What? Not to mention, are you not
literally conceding that every single
woman that you find to be conventionally
attractive that you also feel sexual
impulses for? So you're a married man
struggling with forms of mental
infidelity.
>> So good. Firstly, as you can see, it's a
shame tactic. So it's something
abnormal. So what she's talking about is
for example, which another study um
research kind of debunks, it is called
it's called the western mark effect. The
it's called or reverse sexual
imprinting. It's a hypothetical
psychological effect through which
people we live in close domestic pro
proximity during the first years of uh
of their life become desensitized to
sexual attraction. The effect is not
just only applicable for biological
related families but also incomplete
strangers who were brought up together.
Okay. And the title is called why are we
not attracted to our siblings? The west
the western uh the western mark effect
and self-gene uh theory shows that. So
which is what it is a platonic
relationship. Just because for example I
might say my daughter is very attractive
or for example my mother or my sister
etc. because I've brought up with them
there are so many other factors that
play a key role in why I would not have
that in that specific situation and even
it's applies to people that you may have
grown up with. That kind of attraction
is not there. And even Islamically a boy
and a girl when they reach the age of
seven they are told to sleep in separate
beds. There is a reason for that. I've
witnessed firsthand how crazy it is to
suddenly find myself wildly attracted to
a woman that 8 hours earlier I had no
interest in whatsoever. And I think this
is an unavoidable fact. If you spend a
lot of time around someone and get
emotionally and intimately close to each
other, even if it's platonic, you're
consistently run the risk of developing
romantic or sexual feelings for that
person, even if you've never experienced
them in the past. So, it would suggest
that women are already consciously or
subconsciously aware of the fact that
men are worse at maintaining platonic
relationships. And I suspect a lot of
this has to do with an intimacy gap in
men's lives. Men in general experience a
lot less emotional support from their
friends than women do. If you just have
a look at this study from the UK, you'll
see that women experience twice as much
emotional support from their female
friends as men do. They are likely to be
told they are loved by a friend twice as
often as a man. And they are 60% more
likely to share personal feelings or
problems with their friends. This
represents a massive gap at intimacy
connection that men just aren't getting.
Men usually only receive this level of
intimacy from their romantic
relationships. And so, no wonder it
becomes confusing for us when we
suddenly experience this level of
connection and emotional support from a
woman that's supposed to be platonic.
Because for us, the only time we've ever
experienced that is when we're with
someone romantically.
>> So, then you came and then you come and
say something very uh very bizarre.
Let's hear for oursel inshallah.
>> Because you lack discipline and control,
you're now subjecting your current wife
to your mental infidelity.
>> Good. So, she's saying that because you
lack mental control. So in a nutshell
this is like which talks about barbarism
which is very ironic because in the in
the dark ages when there was actual
barbarism um and I'm not saying Islam
said this but many other religions like
Christianity etc. they see desire having
intimacy and pleasure of intimacy as
something blamew worthy. They see as
unnatural it's like she said hedonistic
and barbaric etc. They would say the
same thing about women. They were
discussing if a woman had a soul. They
would come and say that a woman having
sexual intim pleasure even in the Muslim
world. This is not Islamic that a woman
has no right to sexual intimacy or for I
mean uh for sexual pleasure and that is
not from Islam. So if anything you're
talking about barbarism and hedenism it
goes back to what? It goes back to the
worldview in the dark ages where they
would blame women like you and imagine
you're being told what you're telling me
you call have self-control etc. It's
like imagine a woman being told have
some self-control. Why are you enjoying
pleasure? In Islam, a woman has every
right to enjoy pleasure. Not only that,
a woman who is sexually not satisfied,
who came to the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him and asked for divorce. The
actual basis is what? A woman has a
right. Not only that, we are told that
it is charity to our partners that when
we have intimacy, it's it's like
charity. They have a right to have
sexual gratification and enjoyment.
Imagine I'm scolding a woman and saying,
"How dare you? Did you enjoy that? How
dare you enjoy that? What is the
difference between you and me?" And you
would call that misogynistic. Okay. And
you're doing the same thing with this.
It's misundry because you're saying,
"No, no, no. How dare you?" Well, let's
go to something a bit shocking. Let's
watch this for ourselves.
>> Me personally, I would be sick to my
stomach if my husband was incapable of
looking at a woman who was
conventionally attractive and not think
about her sexually. Because according to
your logic, if we're universalizing it,
that means every single attractive woman
that you see, you want to have sex with
them.
>> Good. And again, this shows the
literally like it's it's they have no
idea. And this is the reason why you
need to understand something, okay?
There are certain things that that
Allahh has created you in. That's why to
your psychology you think this is
abnormal. Now let me tell you something
clearly. Abd that the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him was walking one day.
You're a Muslim woman. He was walking
one day and he happened to see a woman
not looked on purpose. Happened to see
see a woman who he had a desire an
instant. What did we talk about? How a
man's sex a sexual tendencies are there
is no match with a woman. This is why my
dear sister, with all you respect,
you're living in absolute la land. And
we're here to educate both each other to
understand this reality. He saw a woman
had a sexual desire in his heart and
what did he do? He went back to his wife
Zanab and had intimacy with her. Now,
are you going to say, is Zay going to
say, "Oh, I will feel sick to my stomach
to have a husband who goes out and sees
a woman." This is the reality of men.
Welcome to our world. It doesn't make us
sick. It doesn't make us less. This is
how we are created. Why can you not
respect the way we're created? When we
respect the way women's created, you
have menopause, you have the menstrual
cycle, you have hormones up and down.
And as a man, there's so many times
where we are told to be patient with our
wives. There's bits, there's things she
says that she doesn't mean. But when it
comes vice versa, we're like, "Oh, no,
no, no, no. We are made to be inhumane.
How could you? I feel sick to my
stomach." So, the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him. Not only that, go to the
Quran. Gus Yusf, the prophet of Allah,
he Allah says Ysef Alisam when he was
being seduced by the woman, he's a
prophet of God, he had an inclination
towards her and Allah says that we
showed a a the signs of Allah. When the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
when a man and a woman is alone, the
third is Satan. Yes. What are you going
to say? So on what basis are you trying
to defend this premise of, oh, I don't
know why people listen to him. What am I
saying? A man and a woman cannot be
friends. Why are you arguing against
that? Why? Because it's coming from me.
That is so petty. It is so so petty.
Subhan Allah. That you are focused on
that. And not only that, we have got
studies like I'll show you one other
study for example. This is a graph that
shows what women receive more emotional
support from their friends. Percentage
of Americans who report the following
experience in the past week. Men
compared to women. Let's go to men.
Received emotional support from their
friend. Look at it's nearly double the
number pertaining uh when you compare
men to women. Told a friend you love
them. Women are more likely to tell
their friends that they love them
compared to men. Shared personal
feelings or problems with a friend.
Women are nearly as double as likely.
Now, do you know what's interesting
about this study? This means that the
reason why a man and a woman cannot be
friends is because in this study, it
shows that with us as men, when we the
only place where we have this kind of a
woman open and up to us and affection
and I love you and this that is when
it's in marriage. As women you guys get
that you guys perform or explore or um
express those things to your male
counterparts. Now your male counterpart
because they do not have that they only
have that with their partner which is
not platonic which is a sexual
relationship. When they see that from a
woman they say what ah she's interested
in me. But a woman thinks what? No he's
just my friend. And we've seen ample
evidence of people like oh he's just a
friend. Okay call him. Call him and say
that you're interested in him. What's
the result? Oh yeah, yeah, I want to go
on a date. I've been waiting for this
all this all my life. Do you understand
the reality? We cannot be friends.
Period. Islamically, psychologically,
physiologically, you name it.
Biologically, the way we are programmed
and created, we can't be. So the
question is, why are you bringing me
into it? And as if I'm calling for
something strange on what basis? Any
evidence from Islam, Quran, Sunnah, any
studies, any research? No. Based on
what? Just so you can differ with me.
Why? because you don't agree with me.
Sister, let's be grown-ups, inshallah.
Let's carry on watching the video.
>> And you're lying if you say that you
don't find any other woman
conventionally attractive other than
your wife. And honestly, this is an
insult to men. It attempts to paint all
men as hedonistic because you are
hedonistic.
>> So, it's an insult to man. That's the
reason why men are polygamous by nature
because yes, they have that inclination.
And the prophet Muhammad and the hadith
clearly shows that. That's the reason
why men have that and you can't. And the
reason why it's so odd for you in demis
and it's bad and it's barbaric is
because you are not wired like that. Why
is it that men buy adult magazines,
watch adult movies, watch all this kind
of stuff? Do you see women going and
saying, "Oh, I like that man's calves. I
cannot wait to see his fingers or his
calves or you don't have that. You are
not created like that. So why are you
demeaning us and belittling us and
calling us barbarians and hedonistic?"
Because we have a natural inclination to
that. That's how we are created. That's
why men can have multiple partners
because they can cater for that. You
can't. You love one man, that man is
your man. As simple as that. But no, why
do you have to be like me, sister? I've
seen so many of your videos a long time
ago where you just want to be like a
man. No, there's no difference between
us. Islamically, we are not the same.
Why do you find it so hard to grasp
that? Let's carry on, inshallah.
>> Not all men are enslaved by their sexual
desires. Some men are mature and some
men are able to look at a conventionally
attractive woman and separate that from
their sexual desire. They are able to
demarcate between the two because
they're not barbaric. Not to mention, if
you think like this and you encourage
other men to think like this, you are
reinforcing a culture which sexualizes
and objectifies women and which by
extension would sexualize and objectify
your own wife, your daughters, your
sisters, your mother. This is also why a
lot of men are incapable of having
platonic relationships with women like
having an acquaintance that's female. If
you can't look at a conventionally
attractive,
>> so this you see what I mean now? Now
she's turned it into sexual
objectification. Just because the man is
created in that way, no, no, it's sexual
objectification. No, it's not. It's the
reality how God almighty has created us
and that's why there are boundaries in
place. The question is if that is the
case then are you blaming Allah because
Allah has put boundaries. A man and a
woman cannot be friends. They cannot be
in the same place together. You have to
speak to the guardian. Why didn't Allah
say go on dates and get to know each
other? Cuz he knows what will happen. So
again remember what I said. Your problem
is not with me. I'm just being thrown
under the bus because your problem is
with Islam per se because that's how it
comes across because this is a reality.
Why are you denying that reality that
men and women cannot be friends and
those uh things are in place to protect
both genders. This is also why a lot of
men are incapable of having platonic
relationships with women like having an
acquaintance that's female. If you can't
look at a conventionally attractive
>> and then now what you're doing is for
calling for something unnatural. Would
you would your father and your brother
be okay with you having friends? No.
Because they would say listen deep down
I'm a man and I know how I've been
created. It can't be. Let alone we're
living in a hypersexualized society. If
there's anyone we understand that women
men find women I think there was a study
done 60 to 70% men find most women
attractive women I think there only four
they a lot of men that they looked at
they only found 4.5% attractive which
again shows the differences that we have
a lot of men find a lot of women
attractive but men do women do not find
as many men attractive that's the reason
why you're coming from your paradigm of
your logic the way Allah created you and
you think this is so absurd to you It is
not to us. It's not a news. Any man
that's watching this, he's thinking,
"Yeah, darn right." Because you're you
are so far from that reality. And now
you're qualified something that is
against Islam and it's not natural,
which is what? Let's just be friends. We
can be friends. No, you cannot be
friends. You can't be friends and
Islamically and uh Quran and Sunnah and
studies and research clearly show this
reality
>> person and not think of them sexually. I
think we might have issues. There's no
logical explanation for this. Although
you tried to use buzzwords and you tried
to posture it as such. And even if you
did try to provide a logical argument,
you would have to presuppose things that
are absurd. It's not logic, it's
projection. What you actually mean is
when you find women attractive, you
sexualize them. You do not all men.
Unfortunately, not all men are the same.
Do not all men. Unfortunately, not all
men are the same. There are good men out
there and you don't set the standard.
>> Do you see what I'm saying? So the
standard is what? You are guilty. There
are men that not like that. This is you.
My my dis with you respect. If you talk
about absurdity, if there's anything,
you haven't given us any reference, any
research, nothing. No, forget research.
Quran and Sunnah any evidence? Nothing.
I've brought you evidence from the
Quran, from the Sunnah, from research,
from studies, etc. All you've done is
just vent yourself out. That's all
you've done, my dear sister. And this
just shows you how weak your argument
is. And not only that, it just shows
that the perception that you have as a
woman is so far from reality. That's the
reason why Allahhana has ordered the man
to be the leader because there are
certain that's why your guardian is not
your mother, it's your father. Because
we as men, we are logical and rational.
We see through certain things. Do you
get what I'm trying to say? And there
was a study done for example that um
showed two a man and a woman observing a
game being played and the the ones for
example if they were to cheat they get
electric shock they get pain. Yes. Okay.
And uh they also got electric shock when
they did not cheat for example. Okay.
Guess what happened when both the man
and the woman they responded same to a
person who was getting electric shock
unjustly. They did not deserve it was
that's wrong. Yes. And they were they
had empathy. Okay. But however, when the
man who was caught cheating from both
angles, from a man and woman's
perspective, got the electric shock, the
man showed signs of pleasure and the
woman showed signs of empathy. Which
means what? When it comes to judgment,
her judgment is clouded. Why? Because
she said even though even though he is
wrong, but the fact that he got electric
shock, I have empathy from him. A man
had pleasure meaning he got what he
deserved. This is why it shows the
differences we have. And my question and
lastly I'll leave on this. Why is it
that you are so adamantly feminist,
radical feminist, I'm not saying you
are. Yes, you have certain tendencies,
are so hellbent on making men and women
the same. We are not the same. In the
sight of Allah, our deeds are the same.
But we are totally separate beings and
we need to accept that reality. And the
reason I've done this video is because
she's done many videos about me. And
what you're saying, it's not about it's
not that about me. It's basically you're
giving a false message which is
absolutely debunked. With all due
respect, sister, so I don't want this to
be a back and forth. I have nothing
personal against you. You're my sister
in Islam. Yes, may Allah make it easy on
you and myself as well. Okay, but what
I'm seeing is think about it. You came
out here differentiating saying that I
am wrong or for a reason and all you did
was is because I am ali because you
don't like me. I mean imagine if a video
just because of who you are or who that
would be silly. That's what I want to
say in Till next time.